it's fine we have billions of people
around the world when you guys are
growing up especially you tadpoles who
is like you guys growing up you big lug
let's go oh I think for me it was
probably uh Walter Brennan
oh great American actor yeah Walter
Brennan and I you know nobody has a clue
who I'm talking about do they maybe
James let me try again I think for me it
was I I don't know I I was inspired by
so many people
I had great grandparents you know old
frogs old frogs are great inspire
inspirations I'm certainly pretty answer
really help me give me something funny
there's great safecracker Brian there is
he is explosives expert it is Tommy the
toenail Luis oh I love Al Pacino's in
The Godfather Part please Christian yes
I can go impression of email for a
famous line for a movie and then I gotta
get back inside
well not very good early I think that's
more a cappuccino than before I go on
stage I always just look at the mirror
and then look the other way very quickly
yeah thank you boy
you